welcome back to dev ox and we hear this
time to talk about well i think android
right this is omar and this is shed or
is it the other way around we're not
sure anymore yeah I'm not sure either so
welcome guys welcome back to the box
you've been here many years and this is
the second time in a row that you're
here announcing almost the release of
something you know following the release
maybe maybe we try to time the platform
releases with Devex maybe the words
devoxx driven development yes that's a
new process and you're gonna talk about
it's a new veteran there is a process
talk tomorrow so yeah maybe yeah make
sure you you don't miss that one on
parlays it'll be on parlays right if
it's good yes oh yeah okay so it should
be there so we heard to talk about
android for dot 4 that's KitKat the
KitKat released so we announced two
things obviously the software for that
for and some hardware I think I think
there's some new heart oh wait there's
some in my hand open services for
example of the nexus 5 this is the white
model white on black as well as the
black on black both colors okay good two
colors available in a number of
countries from day one yes I don't
remember which ones many countries not
enough not enough whatever it's never
enough and the other ones are a little
more vague to me so there are a number
of European countries for those watching
us in Europe certainly anything you want
to point out about the device other than
the fact that it runs kick out which
we'll talk about a second love to screen
the screens amazing yeah I high
resolution fast smooth nice yeah the
colors are really good and super fast at
device you just like the screen because
it has your wallpaper on it great so
let's talk about a kit kat for that for
this the numbering first of all mean
anything in terms of how mutton features
this work went into this one it's
actually it's exactly point one better
than the previous release okay that's a
good start I would say the the
distinction on the dot releases correct
me if I'm wrong ms API bump so there
could be some new API so you could take
advantage of
if we're not changing the api's
generally we wouldn't do that it
wouldn't be more like a maintenance
release on what we've previously done
it's a question for marketing engineers
we don't decide okay all right next
question we just come up with 6 bugs
good enough okay fine fair enough uh
animation framework is that something
you and what do I even have something
like that users demand animations so I
it's been my personal goal to make
animations almost automatic as far as
they can be so I realize everybody likes
to think about animations as much as I
do but they probably don't have the time
to so the more that we can do to make it
easy for them I think the better the
animations are going to be in
application so the the main thing that
we did this time we have all all kinds
of animation capabilities already but
you have to write a fair amount of code
to get really good animations we made it
easier to do transitional and animations
in fact it's called the feature is
called transitions and you can basically
say start a transition now change your
UI by inflating new layouts or modifying
the views that are there and on the next
frame it will automatically detect what
the changes are in the UI and run some
sort of automatic animation and that's
an API wears a declarative it's it's
both you can declare resources where you
stay this information ahead of time in
addition to layout files or you can in
your code simply say okay change the UI
accordingly call this method on the
transitions interface this is in the
transition basically program yourself
out of your job it wasn't the intention
but I'll have to see whether my badge
works because I know to managers will
let me come back there was one neat
feature that I found which is full
screen or there's probably a better name
gosh you know in Mercer okay so it's
something that we had before so it's the
ability to get rid of the system you I
didn't f bar in the status bar so some
apps were able to do it video playback
for instance okay but now it's open to
all applications we're going to talk
about it in details in our talk what's
new in Android this is going to be at
some code it's very easy to use it makes
a lot of sense for games we must have
content like books magazines okay things
like that great you can take it the main
change being that you can have a full
screen application where they use
can actually interact with the
application while remaining full screen
as opposed to as soon as they tap the
bars come back in which was the previous
behavior so how do i exit that mode you
can swipe from the tub or swept from the
bottom and your car's back can my kids
do that or I hope they can they can do
dinner on the gesture how smarter your
kids let's not get there um another
thing I like and we're not we could try
not to go through all the features and
there will be a great talk i'm sure you
guys will deliver and available on
parlays another interesting feature is
screen recording yes Austin co-developer
I mean it's good for you guys probably
it's great for developers for showcasing
their apps on the store was it work it's
great both for for the for the repairs
great booth because they can showcase
their app on websites they don't have to
use the shaky cam yeah version the
recording it's also you really useful
for debugging you can go frame by frame
in your video and you can select it with
basically it's your preference you can
see that that's actually how we did most
of time so right now there's a command
line tool with adb you type adb shell
screen record and an mpeg-4 or from
android studio there's a new button in
one click you can record a video the
only limitation right now is that you
can only record up to three minutes look
at it good but there's no triggering
this directly from the phone like you
can take a straight job not yet okay um
projects felt so you guys talked about
better last year but it was not good
after all and you need to go on a diet
what's the deal there you know I all
diets rivals anyway so a little too much
better a little more diet needed so this
is about running on on human lower
indices devices so how do you define
this 512 megabytes what we aimed at to
run reasonably well on it turns out that
there's still a bunch of devices still
coming out of the market new with older
releases and the reason is because the
newer releases simply had too much
memory footprint for them to run
comfortably not enough applications
could run simultaneously and so what
we've done is slim down the entire
platform to make it easier to run more
applications in only so how did you
actually do that is that is that the
u.s. level at the app level everywhere
eberjey office new tools new api's lots
of work in the u.s. itself so new kernel
features a lot of changes in the
framework we've also analyzed all the
apps and you know the app developers
work great optimizing the applications
so today we give a bunch of tips and
tricks on what you can do what tools can
you use in your apps and what can you do
to use less memory yourself and very
important because there are a lot of
users out there with phones we know with
it's still a lot of memory 512 megs of
ram yet you know you want as many apps
as possible to run at the same time so
if you want to talk about proc stats
enhancement cylinders per phone stores
in general yeah so I mean you know we
come up with new tools in every release
to help the team itself like optimize
the platform and we make those tools
available so everything we've used on
projects veldt and project better be
sure that these are tools available made
available to developers right in fact
the tips that we talked about in the in
the session that we had earlier today it
was tips for Android developers but they
really came from our own experience it's
the approaches that we use the tools
that we use in the optimizations that we
implement to make the platform smaller
and maybe developers can think about the
same things to make their application
smaller as well great another new
feature is printing support yes
excellent based on PF so it's not just
for printing it's also for generating a
side effect of print of adding support
for printing you can generate pdfs right
oh you can look at that both ways i
suppose but they are independent so we
know if your applications you want to be
able to export pds to just email them or
start and some of course you don't have
to do the printing to use the printing
gps so speaking of physical printers
which ones can you printer with the
protocol you any cloud print label
device so if you have content on your
desktop is going to work with Ramesh any
printer if you have a cloud print
enabled printer it works directly and we
can you can also install plug-ins so on
the Nexus 5 we ship with the HP plugin
so any HP printer or recent HP printer
work but and I'm sure there will be more
plugins on markets on the Play Store is
it right awesome um storage access
framework yes concept of documents and
sort of unified access to different
different places where you can store
things so your application no longer
needs to figure out you know how do I
access the area in SD card where I want
to put it or on the cloud or or if
you're a service that provides storage
like a Dropbox or whatever right out in
the cloud you don't need to figure out
how to expose that to users instead
there's a unified way to both publish
your storage mechanism as well as for
the user to access the publish story so
yeah so it's good for providers as both
as uses is like likely in you know the
modern version of the open dialogue and
chooser yep file chooser thank you ok
cool a promise it's not far it's not
gonna read okay that works oh ok the web
view the wave you guys based on chromium
yeah now big news based on danzo a new
limitation yeah semi p is some of them
have been deprecated but it's a drop-in
replacement nothing to do in your abs
like y which runs on chromium you know
don't actually have a choice right no
you'll have a choice so which is good
cuz you know there's better html5
support the community you're constantly
working on recording things you also get
remote debugging so a value sbu guess
use chrome to remote debug on your phone
which is really useful cool so we had a
lot of people trying it out and then
having some features uh you know finding
out new new new things they can do with
it because with the chromium comes
support with a new set of new features
around the html5 and I mean there are
new apps that you can so haven't you
haven't seen a new apps taking advantage
of html5 yet just get her will see that
coming very short right because this is
where support for html5 will come in in
in in the browser and Android let's see
one more thing I had was SMS provider so
it's we've had an API to the hidden
people were using it was not enough
sharply I so now we have an official API
to access the SMS is on the phone we
have the concept of the default SMS
application so only the default SMS
application as chosen by the user will
be able to write to the SMS database but
you know now we at least we have
official spot for that but to let the
user in control great two more things I
want to cover before we close this one
is tooling can you say a few words on
you know Android studio is there's a lot
of work going on on this and tour is not
or xavier or not here with us on their
behalf i'll talk about all the work that
they've done that I'm not aware of
there's obviously work going on in the
tools all the time anyway but there's
been a huge effort behind Android studio
it's still early release beta release I
don't forget what the official
terminology google i/o preview 0 yeah
strangely it's been a zero point three
point four just came out this week and
it provides one of the one of the
changes is there's some language level
changes so you can now take advantage of
things like strings and switch statement
to go to that i'm so diamond operators
the multi multi exception catch and the
resource closing i forget we measure
resistance management so the cool thing
about these language features it all of
them except the last one the resource
management is there available on any
platform release because the davat
compiler basically will just compile to
whatever it needs to be it it's kind of
syntactic sugar right all right on the
resource closing is well your resource
management is a capability of the
platform you need to do because there's
an API based I mean there's an interface
you need to implement yeah so so that
was the actually last point I want to
get to is that you get all those
language evolution which actually a lot
of them do make sense for Android
developers yeah so there you know LG
cash and then features in the auto
closeable is pretty and Ellen one or two
divided support for drawable previews
the integrated DDMS skiing better so you
can start screen recording from farm and
roads to do directly there's a new
traceview I that's very similar to
systrace excessively always want to use
I mean they're coming out with new new
releases all the time
you know every time you do a pretty
pretty amazing job at coming up with new
features so yeah okay great exciting
well I guess so guys that's all the time
we have for thanks for showing up with a
cue our friend here yes and I think you
know go get there and then use those
api's and then provide feedback that's
so I guess our call to action here
thanks sounds good thanks thank you